wir alle kennen rezeptvideos auf tiktok
manche sind absoluter Quatsch und andere
sehen zu gut aus und wahr zu sein aber
eine Sache haben sie gemeinsam man
speichert sie und kocht sie niemals nach
wir machen es uns heute zur Aufgabe
genau das zu ändern wir kochen die
ersten Rezepte die uns ins Auge springen
und gucken ob sie was taugen los geht's
also Leute ich nehme euch jetzt mit in
meinen Innerstes auf meine for you page
ich schnapp mir hier mein Handy und wir
scrollen einfach mal wild drauflos das
Ding ist ich könnte richtig Pech haben
und es könnte halt vor real auch so ein
15 Stunden Gericht sein deshalb hoffe
ich dass es das ist flott geht und auch
gut schmeckt was wir zubereiten weil ich
habe auch schon richtig Hunger
da ist schon das erste Flugzeug boah das
sieht so gut aus sticky goshuan misos
Salmen source kriegen wir halt im hier
sind ingredient sogar perfekt ich
schwöre daran ist nichts gestellt dass
das dritte tiktok das kam so leute wir
waren einkaufen und wie Mister Grab
workses sagt
Danke
haben einmal großschwangpasste einmal
helle misso zuckermirin und Zacke sowie
ein wunderschönes Lachsfilet Gossau habe
ich zum ersten Mal gekauft deshalb weiß
ich auch nicht ob es gerade richtig
ausspreche aber diese passte hier
ist das weshalb ich Ski so Burger so
sehr liebe Berlin Fußballplatz erinnert
euch ich kann komplett auf den Burger da
ab und es könnte auch nicht einfacher
sein wir nehmen einfach alles und
schütten ist in diesem Kopf hier
zusammen fangen wir an mit Zucker dann
einmal Zacke Mirin könnte auch andersrum
sein ich wüsste es nicht ihr wisst es
genauso wenig verpasste Gott schon
passte und es sollte wenn es jetzt
verrühren für eine kräftige
Branche Farbe bekommen wir haben auf
jeden Fall die Konsistenz erreicht die
ja auch hatte wunderschön glänzend so
soll es sein jetzt kümmern wir uns um
den Fisch Marinade rein ein bisschen was
bewahren wir uns auf weil er hat das
auch noch getoppt am Ende mit der
Marinade als erstes mit der Fleischseite
runter jetzt folgt die nächste Seite wow
die Farbe direkt marinieren auch die
Hautseite und jetzt lassen wir das ganze
auf der Fleischseite zum Marinieren
schließen es mit Klarsichtfolie und
verarbeiten ihn dann weiter unser Lachs
ist mariniert etwa eine halbe Stunde
vielleicht wir gucken mal ob das ganze
auch so Reichweite ehrlich 5 Stunden
oder ein bis zwei Tage war ich auf jeden
Fall nicht wir nehmen den Lachs PIN sind
ein wenig unserer Marinade noch
einarbeiten das schützt ihn
wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen vom
Austrocknen weil er geht jetzt bei 220
Grad in den Ofen Timer auf 12 Minuten
und gucken wir wann er so aussieht am
besten dann verlässt sich auf die Augen
wir haben die Farbe immer noch nicht
erreicht aber ich hole den Lachs jetzt
raus wenn nicht riskieren dass er
irgendwie zu durch sein wird wir wollen
dieses glasiger am Ende noch haben ja
auf jeden Fall jetzt direkt mit dem
Sesam drin ist der schön anhaftet dann
sieht das Ganze auch ohne dunkle Pass
schon echt richtig gut aus finde ich
jetzt sagt er Redding ist das heißt
warten jetzt bis das ganze ein bisschen
abgekühlt ist vielleicht 10 Minuten und
dann lassen wir uns endlich schmecken
[Musik]
alter Schwede sieht das gut aus der Reis
den haben wir einfach einem Reiskocher
gemacht falls ihr euch fragt wo der
herkommt der Lachs wow ihr habt
vielleicht gerade gesehen unfassbar
saftig ist der auch in der Mitte ich
glaube das ist wirklich ein verdammt
gutes Rezept was wir haben ich probiere
direkt mal ein bisschen Frühlingszwiebel
Lachs und Reis ich glaube das ist
wahrscheinlich so mit das unaufwändigste
hübsche Gericht dass ich in letzter Zeit
gekocht habe das war eine wirklich drei
Handgriffe und ein bisschen Zeit
[Musik]
nochmal schön die heiße Soße und top
süße Schafe leicht salzige es hat auf
jeden Fall aber schon so eine süße
dominierende Note dass du der Lachs der
perfekt glasig ist das ist geil und das
ist richtig nice das ist tiktok gibt
damit ich das jetzt ausprobiert habe das
erste war ja wirklich brutal Leute ich
hätte es mir nicht vorstellen können
dass es so lecker ist aber wir brauchen
noch weitere Gerichte deshalb schauen
wir direkt mal was uns sonst noch so
vorgeschlagen wird Messi solo Golds Aldi
Nord gute Beats Challenge
ich würde sagen das ist kein Rezept das
müssen wir auf jeden Fall nicht kochen
das ist halt wieder mit Lachs aber das
sieht richtig richtig gut aus Lexa kenne
ich gar nicht den Begriff sieht für mich
aus wie so eine Rahmen mit
Kokosnussmilch und Erdnuss crazy falls
ihr übrigens auch andere hochqualitative
Vorschläge wird dann guck mal hier
vorbei ich hatte einfach auch Max pane
bei tiktok und mach auch da übrigens
Rezepte
hier auf Youtube schaut aber lohnt sich
mal vorbei zu gucken okay simply swap
the Samen for France oder whatever also
wir können das Modifizieren dann würde
ich sagen ist es was anderes würde mich
sehr interessieren und das geht auch in
15 Minuten weiter geht's mit unserem
zweiten Rezept ich habe ein bisschen was
vorbereitet zum Beispiel diese Julienne
aus Karotten geschnitten ganz ehrlich
das ist ein bisschen mehr als wir dann
eben hatten aber trotzdem ist es noch
ein verdammt einfaches Rezept das
Erkennen auch direkt an der Vielfalt von
Zutaten die wir haben einmal Hühnerbrühe
Honig Austernsoße Fischsoße Sojasauce
Erdnussbutter rote Curry Paste ein
bisschen Tofu als Topping Kokosnussmilch
Limette Karotte Frühlingszwiebel machen
wir unseren Herd heiß und geben zunächst
einmal unsere rote Curry Pasta rein wie
beim ersten Rezept arbeiten hier mit so
passt und ich glaube das ist schon
ziemlich genial weil so hat man einfach
so ein Instant flavour Boost man muss
nichts lange köcheln lassen man muss
nicht 10.000 Gewürze zusammenwerfen das
ist schon ziemlich Smart die emily hat
das Ganze auch noch mal in die Video
Beschreibung geschrieben deshalb kann
ich immer noch mal schön stecken ich
werde euch auch alle original tiktoks
unten in der Videobeschreibung verlinken
falls euch irgendjemanden zugesagt hat
nicht wir sollen das ganze ein bisschen
anbraten steht so im Rezept in der Paste
wir haben direkt so ein bisschen was am
Boden stecken und unsere passte sieht
auch ein bisschen anders aus
direkt ein bisschen in sich also richtig
Chilli höchste Zeit unsere kokosmilchen
zuzugeben und obendrauf jetzt kommt halt
dieser Moment wo diese trübe dicke Soße
entsteht oh es geht auch direkt los ist
schon geil ne das ist langsam
aufgeköchelt das heißt jetzt kommt
unsere Erdnussbutter hinzu diese geile
holländische wie heißt die auch passte
stand da nur drauf lösen wir jetzt auch
ein bisschen drin auf schaut mal wie
dick flüssig unseres Hauses ja wir haben
nämlich die Hühnerbrühe drin aber bei
ihr sieht das ganze so super flüssig aus
weiß ich nicht wir geben erstmal unsere
Hühnerbrühe dazu also noch ein bisschen
Geflügelbrühe rein gehen also unsere
Nudeln hinein das ganze köchelt vor sich
hin ich habe gerade eben ein bisschen
probiert das hatte richtig panisch
richtig Schärfe deshalb ein bisschen
Sorger am Ende noch unintelligible dazu
Mamma Mia das könnte hart werden wir
geben jetzt noch die Hälfte unserer
Karotten rein also Karotten dazu dann
auch weich werden und die zeste einer
Limette ist schon geil ne das sind so
geile kleine Tricks und Methoden die wir
hier anwenden um das wirklich
geschmacksvoll hin zu zaubern nehmen wir
uns den Saft einer Hälfte reindrücken
gehen wir jetzt unsere Soßen dazu
Fischsoße gerade einmal nach riechen das
ist unser Honig den für die Götter oder
so ja ich habe hier so ein frittierten
Tofu gekauft den liebe ich einfach der
ist so richtig schön wolkige gerade mit
so einer Suppe funktioniert das richtig
gut weil er saugt sich auch wie ein
Kissen damit voll unser Tofu Brett an
der war zwar nicht streng genommen
Rezept aber er hat eine richtig schöne
Kruste hier schon bekomme ich liebe
diesen Popo boah richtig geil hier
drüben sollte unsere Nudeln auf langsam
aber sicher fertig werden
drin ne wie findet ihr das eigentlich
dass man oben rechts und links nicht die
Lichter sieht so wie sonst
immer so heute versuchen wir das Ganze
für euch mal
außer Acht zu lassen
immer hübscher für euch zu machen und
das ist ein Teil der Arbeit
Fische noch ich weiß nicht ob die
Mengenangaben in der Beschreibung stimmt
weil das ist wirklich brutal intensiv
vom Geschmack
[Musik]
okay lass uns das ganze probieren als
allererstes fällt wirklich auf wir haben
eine viel dickere Suppe erhalten als sie
und ich glaube das liegt vor allem an
der currypass den wir verwendet haben
weil die mussten andere benutzen sie
muss weniger benutzt haben als sie
geschrieben hat es ist auf jeden Fall
schon was anderes aber es sieht trotzdem
verdammt gut ausprobieren
[Musik]
also ich würde sagen das hat über 100 %
Player intensity zu geschmackvoll schon
fast das könnten übelst geiles Gericht
sein also ich glaube das müsste man
jetzt halt fein tun weniger passte mehr
Kokosmilch bisschen vielleicht Wasser
noch dazu geben das ist ein bisschen
flüssiger wird geschmacklich das was wir
haben ist wirklich wirklich gut ist das
jetzt ein gutes Rezept oder eine
schlechtes wenn jetzt jemand der gut gar
nicht kochen kann mit dem Rezept Video
konfrontiert wäre würde vielleicht noch
über einen als dass wir hier gemacht
haben wir sehen uns beim nächsten
Gericht wieder beim letzten Gericht wow
also ohne Witz die bisherigen Rezepte
waren wirklich wirklich gut und glaube
wir brauchen zumindest eins was nicht
gut ist weil ich habe langsam das Gefühl
es kann nicht noch ein gutes kommen
manchmal sind die so sinnlos und ich
will zumindest mal gucken ob wir noch
eins bekommen was uns ein bisschen
überrascht und ist Essen Alter Carbonara
[Musik]
Routine also
Zucchini Carbonara ich glaube das könnte
unser drittes Rezept sein weil da bin
ich mir jetzt nicht 100% sicher dass es
super nice ist also es wird garantiert
schmecken aber die Frage ist wie gut bei
unseren anderen Rezepten war ich mir
sicher dass sie krass werden und sie war
noch krass machen wir eine Zucchini
Carbonara ich habe immer noch Hunger das
heißt wir machen uns das dritte Gericht
und ich muss euch sagen ich bin gespannt
weil eine Carbonara mit Zucchini kann
die so gut sein wie eine richtige
karbonara ich würde jetzt vorher erstmal
sagen nein kommt auf jeden Fall nicht
ran aber ich glaube schon dass sie gut
schmecken kann wir geben erstmal jede
Menge Olivenöl in eine große Pfanne und
Frittieren dann darin die Zucchini neben
der Zucchini brauchen wir noch Nudeln
natürlich gebogenen Hand geformten extra
lange Spaghetti drei Eier und Parmesan
Käse die Pfanne mit Öl ist heiß und wir
geben unsere Zucchini hinein Braten die
einmal schön durch die sehen auch
genauso aus wie ein tiktok das heißt ich
glaube wir werden auf jeden Fall jetzt
genau das richtige Ergebnis erzielt
selbst gut oder schlecht Nudelwasser
Salzen
der Drop wer ist noch nicht gecheckt hat
Block ist meine Brand ich werde eigene
Küchenwagen auf den Markt bringen ich
bin sehr aufgeregt viele von euch haben
sich schon den Newsletter eingetragen
über 5000 genauso auf Instagram vorbei
geschaut das wird auf jeden Fall
spannend bald ist soweit und ich sage
auch bald alles also was es geben wird
worum es geht und was mir dabei so
gedacht haben eine Sache habe ich aber
nicht verstanden dass sie diese Eier
Parmesan Mischung in den Kühlschrank
gestellt haben weil was soll das denn
machen was bringt das dass das kühl ist
vielleicht besser ich weiß nicht bisher
immer geklappt bei mir rein
Kochzeit zwölf Minuten ich habe hier
einen Teller mit Zewa auf den werde ich
jetzt vorsichtig die Zucchini geben habt
ihr noch ein bisschen bis aber das ist
doch gar nicht falsch es soll definitiv
etwas Öl in der Pfanne zurück bleiben
deshalb ist glaube ich gut ist dass wir
das hier Löffel so vorsichtig rausheben
jetzt nehme ich mir eine Schüssel und
gebe in die Schüssel ein ganzes Ei und
zwei Eigelb jetzt verquirlen wir unsere
Eier und geben jetzt den Käse dazu dass
wir diese klassische Carbonara passte
erhalten Parmesan ist komplett in
unserer Schüssel jetzt geht unser Homie
mit einem bisschen Nudelwasser dran
dabei wird kräftig gerührt dass sei auf
keinen Fall auf die Idee kommt zu
stoppen lassen ist jetzt ruhen ich werde
es nicht in den Kühlschrank wobei wir
müssen eigentlich alles machen
wir gehen jetzt schon mal ein bisschen
Nudelwasser in unser Öl hinüber damit
das Ganze schon mal anfangen kann hierzu
geben wir jetzt also unsere Nudeln
hinein und ab auf die Hitze ein bisschen
Pfeffer an unsere Zucchini guck mal rein
was ist sieht so aus ja und dann machen
die gar nichts dann kommt ein zwischen
Soße drauf und fertig und geht kommt
nichts sondern es ist einfach nur
perfekte Soße weil da ist ja die
eigentliche Schwierigkeiten raus jetzt
gehen wir die eierkäse Mischung oben
drauf und halten es direkt in Bewegung
so dass das ganze schön ineinander
schmelzen kann
das ist halt wirklich sehr sehr
creamy aber man muss auf dem Teller oder
[Musik]
das letzte unserer drei tik tok Rezept
ist fertig und ich muss sagen es sieht
schon echt gut aus ich will mich erstmal
von dieser Krämer hier vorne überzeugen
oh so eine dezente aubergine-note ist da
gut dass die Aubergine da wieder ist
die Zucchini Hotel ist auf jeden Fall da
boah aber die ist auch wirklich brutal
probieren wir mal ein paar Zucchini
Stückchen mit ein bisschen Nudeln und
Sauce kann ich euch sagen empfehlen
würde das ganze nachzukaufen das hier
ist die perfekte Gabel gesehen
Cremigkeit der Pasta wir sehen die
Zucchini und wir lassen es uns schmecken
schöne Pasta die Zucchini hat einen
schönen Biss behalten wenn ich das blind
verkostet hätte hätte ich halt nicht an
Carbonara gedacht du hast viel zu diese
klassische Carbonara Charakteristik
könnt ihr verstehen was ich meine meine
Nummer eins mit Abstand heute war der
Lachs unglaublich drei vier einfache
Handgriffe ein bisschen Wartezeit und
dann hat wirklich eine
Geschmacksexplosion von der man vorher
nur träumen konnte aber auch die anderen
beiden Rezepte waren wirklich gut
vielleicht muss man da ein bisschen
genauer hingucken um sie originalgetreu
nach zu kochen aber ich würde sagen
dafür dass wir das zum ersten Mal
gemacht haben ist es echt gut geglückt
wir hätten auch komische Rezepte
bekommen können ich bin happy wenn ihr
auch seid dann lasst gerne einen like da
wir sehen uns beim nächsten Video wieder
und check-block vom Job ich küss eure
Herzen ciao